every soul will have a soulmate Scott
Disick reacts to being told he's
Kourtney Kardashian's soul mates
really cute if I was Sophia I would be
so insecure on Sunday night's episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
the sisters sought out spiritual
guidance on their family vacation to
Bali and while Kim and Khloe's didn't go
as planned at first
Horton Scott's was telling it's up to
you how you want to end up dis life
together or not together when the
spiritual healer tells Kourtney myself
that were soul mates it's a lot to hear
I don't really know what to think I'm in
another relationship Scott is in another
relationship with 20-year old model
Sophia Richie yeah well that gave us all
the fields but when the pair broke it
down later on they agreed they're better
off co-parenting as friends we have
three children we love each other I
don't know what the definition of
soulmate is but Scott and I were going
to be in each other's lives forever
Khloe and Kim finally found the reading
they were looking for sometime you
didn't trust the person that you witness
and
and that's why kind of costing you this
like unstable KOCO opened up for the
first time on the show about her
internal struggles over staying with her
daughter truths dad force in Thompson
after the cheating scandal that rocked
their relationship before her birth ever
since what's happened between Tristan
and I nobody knows I fight an inner
battle with myself in regards to what is
the best thing to do for my relationship
and for me this woman is spot on with me
and it's kind of freaking me out I'm
gonna figure it all out I promise you
and well you know secondly boy that's
where he's gonna be reincarnated Kim's
reading revealed that bit of info giving
us insight into her fourths little ones
potential name the birth of Kim and
hubby Kanye West's second baby boy to
celebrated before the Bali episode aired
with a CBD inspired baby shower
including sound baths and marijuana
plants I feel really calm and at ease